about 6 million people latest data
coming from going into the 2012 election
were unable to vote because of a
previous criminal conviction and it
varies from state to state Florida is at
the very high end of that studies have
been done and said that this actually
impacts elections if you think about how
many what portion of those people would
have voted how many of them would likely
have voted for a Democrat and you
correct for socio-economic data that
these are people coming from lower
socioeconomic status or less like the
vote you run all that saying all things
being equal that in fact had you not had
such massive dissing felon
disenfranchisement in Florida the
Democrats Al Gore would have easily won
the state and therefore easily would
have won the 2000 election and none of
us would have known what hanging chads
are we also had data that's done on the
in the 1990s and said that a number of
governor's races would have gone in a
different way had there not been this
massive felon disenfranchisement and
also P Senate races as well so it
affects it's so huge and it's so
concentrated in certain states because
some certain states don't have felon
disenfranchisement at all and then
certain states like Florida have massive
felon and Virginia massive felon
disenfranchisement that it affects
outcomes of elections after the Civil
War there was an effort to
disenfranchise African Americans and
also poor whites because there were
fears about the populist movements and
blacks and whites joining together so in
the late 19th century early 20th century
we had a massive disenfranchisement in
this country some states like Louisiana
the turn of the century only about 15%
of the eligible quote-unquote eligible
adult male population was actually
voting because of these massive
disenfranchisement so poll taxes
literacy taxes but also laws that said
if you had certain criminal convictions
you would not be able to vote and
ironically in some states because it was
so targeted towards the african-american
population in some states it was
towards people who committed petty
crimes so we still have in one or two
southern states where you could have
committed homicide but you're still
allowed to vote but if you committed
petty theft and convicted that you're
not allowed to vote and this is a
vestige from the Civil War years where
whites were more likely to have you know
committed homicide and african-americans
were going to be picked up for many of
these more petty crimes and therefore be
disenfranchised some states have been
extending the franchise again so they
had a very important ballot measure in
Rhode Island a few years ago and a very
effective campaign led by formerly
incarcerated people some of whom had
done very serious crimes and they were
able to frame this issue in a way that
resonated with the public and in fact
Rhian franchised a number of people in
some other states we've had backsliding
depending on a switch in the legislature
a switch in in the governor's offices
but I think it's important to see felon
disenfranchisement as part of this
larger big contraction of the u.s.
population voting population now so it's
part of voter ID voter registration
closing down polling booths reducing the
number of days that people can vote and
in the 2000 and election election it
wasn't just that people were
disenfranchised but it was also how that
was politically used so there was not an
effort to have accurate lists of voters
so that there you would not only
disenfranchised but you had an
inaccurate list and then you had the
fears of people going to vote that day
and being told you're a convict so then
that's going to keep you home too
because of that that public stigma so I
think when we think felon
disenfranchisement we can't just think
about these six million people we have
to think that this is a larger strategy
about shrinking the electorate in the
United States